that was on Legion of skanks the podcast
Legion of skanks and they uh tricked a
Fox news reporter that was doing a
documentary about comedy and uh she
thought she was talking to Dave
Chappelle so I pranked phone called her
as Dave Chappelle and she believed it
for a good five to six minutes and I was
just walking my dog in New Jersey and
what did you tell her I was so it was
through our friend LS J Gomez and uh you
know they were like what bid are you
going to do like how are you going to
mess with her and I was like I'm just
going to keep she thought LS J Gomez
Who's A friend of mine been a longtime
friend of mine she thought he was very
close to Dave Chappelle he's not I don't
think he's ever met Dave Chappelle why
did she think he was close to Dave
Chappelle because she was like oh we
want to get Dave on this comedy
documentary and she was saying Dave and
he thought she meant Dave Smith from the
Legion of skanks podcast and he was like
oh I'll give you Dave's number he's like
a brother to me and so she thought it
was Dave Chappelle and so she was like
it's such an honor to text you
and then Tim butterly a really funny
Philly comedian was on the podcast and
he was like you guys should prank phone
callers Dave Chappelle and big J was
like soda does a perfect Chappelle you
should call her and uh I was playing a
video game and he called me and he's
like hey will you make this prank phone
call and I grew up doing prank phone
calls so I was like yeah I would love to
and so I called her they called her on
um you know like three-way calling and
then I just tricked her into thinking
Dave Chappelle was best friends with
Louis J Gomez is that is that online now
yeah it's on YouTube they they've
clipped it but it's uh it was very funny
because is it yours can we use can we
you guys can Heir it I guarantee they
would love if you aired it uh okay let's
put up that call cuz I want you to talk
us through it as you're I love my
favorite thing even more than TV and
podcasting is prank calls it was what I
started it was like kind of like the
first uh realization that I was funny
was when I would prank phone call with
my friends and I grew up right at the
age where star 67 became a thing right
so then it was like for those that don't
know star 67 is where you can block your
block your number so you can prank phone
call you're off the grid and it was
unbelievable what's your favorite prank
call of all time the one of the I used
to call grocery stores telling them that
the food got me sick and I would just
describe the sickness that I got and to
keep them on the phone uh there was one
time I called like to that same uh kind
of uh Lane I us to said one of my best
friends ever was uh Gilbert Godfrey one
of the funniest human beings of all time
and one of the sweetest men of all time
so we used to sit at the Carnegie Deli
and at the Carnegie Deli in New York
it's kind of a group table like tourists
and everybody sits like
shoulder-to-shoulder with strangers you
don't get your own table there's no
table for two there's two seats at a
table Yeah rip Carnegie Deli I know who
was so fun there's something called The
Carnegie Deli but it's not the car it's
not it but but we used to sit there and
I used to say and we then there'd be
tourist that we would be shoulder toosh
shoulder and I'd say to him like how you
doing they go well I can't do I don't do
what why would I yes but he used to go I
got a a fluid yeah seeping from my ass I
love it it's like a puss and people are
sitting there with their corn beef
sandwiches and but he would do that so
let's let's hear put this on play
fighting PC culture if you're if the
closest thing you have to a brother
Louis J Gomez happens to come up feel
free feel free to roll with that for a
little bit okay so they're they're
setting it up this is them setting it up
to me all right all right all right I'm
muting and now adding
call
okay so you're getting a fox person on
them yeah they called they're calling
producer not m shut up Dave and I'm
already on the phone so I know she
thinks this is Dave Chappelle calling
her oh hey Dave how are
you join join this is such prank phone
call
Energy hello hey how you doing hey I'm
good I'm on a train so apologies can you
hear me oh it's quite all right I'm
outside I just want to call you real
quick CU I know I I only have about four
minutes that's okay I have like 1%
batteries oh I just I wanted to get in
quick and talk to you about Louis J
Gomez easily one of the funniest people
I've ever met in my life so as I was
doing this I was I was walking my dog
right and I'm like walking around
Hoboken New Jersey being like man I love
Louis J
Gomez
I can't get enough of them I find them
to be a very important part of comedy
and as I'm doing it at one point in this
call I was picking up like my dog
we got we got you don't have to say
your dog it wasn't you it was me taking
a nice hot dump but I remember I like to
pick up strange I just pick it up
and I feel and I remember I turned the
corner and I was I was talking pretty
loud on the phone right and this guy
comes around the corner he like looks at
me and he's like I could just see that
he he was like I thought I heard Dave
Chappelle but it's just me holding a bag
of poop with a mut keep going let's is
very important to me he is like a
brother yes I've been with him through
sick and sin we have established a a
connection that is a bond that is
unbreakable yes yes I would honestly say
I'm take a bullet for Lou J you know he
was incredible I I met him at gas
digital and he was so influential gas
digital is is crazy how hard I've seen
work on it and how incredible the one
problem is is the website I keep telling
them I say louw you got to fix the
website so I don't know that they're
reacting like this I'm just like on my
phone part of the best part of prank
phone calling is when your friend is in
the other room and they have their hand
you know they a hand on the receiver and
they're like what are you doing and
you're like I'm getting nuts so I didn't
know how it went and then they hung up
and they were like and that was when I
watched this clip was the first time I
got to see the people reacting to it
that's fantastic did you make a did you
make any did you give her any misin
besides you knowing lisis B Gomez and
him being the great no Louis Jay Gomez
he would he would get mad at me if I I'm
Canadian and the exchange rate on a j is
a be he um the the fun part was just
like she always was trying to as she
tried to move it back to a regular
conversation I would subtly bring it
back to just wanting to talk about Lewis
Le so she would be like well what do you
think of the state of comedy and I'd be
like well Louis J Gomez
[Music]
all